à magny les hameaux le maire sortant
sera bien candidat bertrand guillon
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes à la tête de
la ville depuis 2012 suite à la
démission de jacquelot lloze vous serez
en lice pour un troisième mandat lors de
ces municipales tête de liste et du
collectif ensemble pour magny les
hameaux c'était une évidence pour vous
de vous présenter à nouveau pour ce
scrutin
l'évidence une continuité on va dire
puisque le travail qui a été effectué et
collectivement à manille avec l'équipe
municipale a permis d'avancer dans des
transformations de la ville dans une
continuité de service public dans une
mobilisation des habitants et on propose
tout simplement aux habitants pouvoir
continuer tout ça donc poursuivre des
projets quel bilan vous faites sur ce
dernier mandat s'était finalement votre
premier mandat complet à la tête de
magny les hameaux
alors ce mandat était complexe d'un côté
puisque on est face à un assèchement des
finances locales
et puis à des changements de périmètre
de l'agglomération de compétences aussi
ou de partage de compétences entre les
communes et d'agglomération donc il a
fallu faire avec tout ça se battre aussi
pour une continuité des services publics
de proximité se mobiliser pour pouvoir
permettre aux habitants d'accéder
toujours à leurs services mais aussi de
pouvoir transformer la commune en terme
de transition écologique en termes de
participation citoyenne en termes de
renforcement du lien social
donc tout sans la mener
avec à la fois un certain nombre
d'actions fait avec les habitants et
puis beaucoup de mobilisations vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble des partenaires de la
commune on a parlé de ces thématiques
dans un instant puisqu'elles font partie
de vos priorités aussi pour le prochain
mandat sur lequel vous êtes candidat
vous êtes bien sûr un homme de gauche
bertrand ou lyon aujourd'hui sous la
bannière de génération le mouvement de
benoît hamon votre liste et pourtant
revendiqué sans étiquette pourquoi ce
choix finalement les étiquettes importe
peu halliche elle à l'échelle d'une
commune c'est l'important ce n'est pas
l'étiquette c'est les valeurs qu'on
défend on met trop les jambes bandées
dans des boxes dans des cases et moi je
ne défends pas un parti je ne dépends
pas non plus d'un parti chacun doit
garder sa liberté par contre il est
essentiel que nous soyons attachés à des
valeurs fortes
des valeurs qui permettent le progrès
social des valeurs qui permettent la
solidarité des valeurs qui permettent de
vivre en harmonie avec notre
environnement
des valeurs qui permettent de faire
confiance aux citoyens et de les
associer de co élaborés avec l'ensemble
des habitants avec tout simplement nos
voisines à nos voisins
et forcément à partir de là avec ces
valeurs là je ne vais pas demander à des
gens qui veulent s'investir qui
s'investissent déjà pour beaucoup sur la
commune dans quelle partie son etc
à partir du moment où ces valeurs nous
réunissent nous avons signé ensemble une
charte de l'engagement qui est public
d'ailleurs qui est sur le site
d'ensemble pour manille sur laquelle on
retrouve lançant des valeurs et puis la
méthode qui nous unit et puis bah du
coup à l'intérieur de la liste et puis
de l'équipe beaucoup plus large tu es
qui est notre notre collectif bien nous
avons des gens qui adhèrent peut-être
dans les partis d'autres pas du tout des
gens qui sont en tout cas très actif au
niveau de la commune et qu'ils ont
à coeur de pouvoir s'investir pour les
autres il votre équipe samx aussi bien
des élus actuels comme des nouveaux
visages
il ya un renouvellement forcément et
donc on a des élus qui vont continuer
sur en tout cas qui souhaitent continuer
sur sur le prochain mandat
et puis des personnalités nouvelles on a
ce renouvellement classique
alors depuis le début de l'année vous
organiser des ateliers citoyens ça c'est
pour préparer votre programme pour le
prochain mandat
alors on a d'abord commencé par ce qu'on
a appelé des cafés citoyens
on l'avait déjà organisé pendant le
mandat l'objectif étant de pouvoir
partager le bilan avec les habitants de
pouvoir discuter du bilan et depuis de
pouvoir aussi entrevoir avec eux les
éléments qu'il est où les choses à
améliorer affaires à faire progresser ou
arrêter tout simplement
donc ça ça nous a permis de finaliser
notre bilan en décembre et en janvier on
est passé cette fois sur le projet et
donc on a mis en place des ateliers
citoyens pour pouvoir travailler donc
par différents groupes sur les
thématiques pour pouvoir créer le projet
municipal pour les années à venir
non justement la participation des
citoyens c'est l'un des quatre grands
thèmes que vous défendez ça veut dire
quoi associer davantage les citoyens la
décision communale ça veut dire c'est
l'idée ça veut dire qu élaboré avec les
avec les habitants on a déjà engagé un
certain nombre de choses pendant le
mandat on va continuer de développer ces
choses là ça a été de mettre en place
des ateliers sur les différents projets
de la commune des ateliers où les
habitants volontaires bon on définit
tout simplement le projet le cahier des
charges et et se sont investis pour la
transformation de leur commune c'est
aussi sur la gestion urbaine de
proximité des réunions régulières avec
les habitants pour qu'ils puissent nous
relayer des informations sur la vie
quotidienne dans leur quartier
tout simplement autour de chez eux pour
pouvoir faire des réaménagements pour
pouvoir régler des difficultés de la vie
quotidienne qu'ils peuvent avoir
et puis c'est aussi faire participer les
gens directement comme dans le conseil
de gestion par exemple du centre social
qui est le lieu d' initiatives des
habitants quelqu'un qui veut créer
un atelier qui veut créer une activité
pour pour les autres ou faire une sortie
pour pouvoir emmener ses voisins peut le
faire dans le cadre de son social tout
ça l'objectif c'est de l'amplifier et
surtout de le rendre finalement
totalement officiel que ce mode de
fonctionnement à magny les hameaux
souhaite une norme alors parlant de la
transition écologique qui est l'une des
autres priorités on rappelle que la
commune est membre du parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
pendant votre mandat des bâtiments ont
été réhabilités des bâtiments
énergivores
vous souhaitez également voir apparaître
sur les toits de magny les hameaux des
panneaux photovoltaïques donc s'engager
davantage dans les énergies
renouvelables
là encore on a engagé la démarche
pendant ce mandat une démarche forte
vis-à-vis de la biodiversité vis-à-vis
des mobilités et vis-à-vis de la
rénovation énergétique qui un fort enjeu
dans l'ensemble de notre territoire sur
la rénovation énergétique on a travaillé
avec l'agencé locale de l'énergie et du
climat et on a choisi durant le mandat
les trois plus bâtiments les plus
énergivores
le dernier les travaux vont commencer
cette année c'est le bâtiment du gymnase
auguste delaune
et bien entendu on va continuer cette
démarche et à côté de ça nous avons
travaillé par rapport à des énergies
renouvelables on a aujourd'hui par
exemple notre sens technique municipal
qui est alimenté par une chaudière bois
et avec le parc naturel régional nous
réfléchissons par rapport à l'énergie
photovoltaïque donc d'énergie solaire en
coopération avec cherche des toits après
que opératif citoyenne donc qui est à
l'initiative ou accompagné par par le
parc naturel un cerveau deux réunions
ont eu lieu directement à manille on
leur prête les locaux pour pouvoir
organiser tout ça et nous avons décidé
de pouvoir leur mettre à disposition des
toitures de bâtiments publics et
aujourd'hui donc les études vont avoir
lieu par ce collectif pour pouvoir voir
les positionnements des toits
voir aussi les longueurs de fils à tirer
si si nécessaire et puis finalement
finaliser la faisabilité de ces éléments
là l'objectif encore et au delà de
rendre les bâtiments moins énergivores
de pouvoir aussi avoir des alternatives
en termes d'énergie un mix énergétique
dernière chose c'est aussi la transition
écologique peut être réduire là le
problème de circulation sur la commune
vous souhaitez notamment relier le
réseau cyclable existante saint quentin
en yvelines
aures de magny les hameaux aussi avoir
davantage de bus sur l'accord sur le
réseau cyclable
on a déjà progressé d'accord pendant ce
mandat pas encore totalement il ya
encore des des cheminements à régler
nous aurons du travail aussi en terme de
stationnement plus sécurisé de
déploiement aussi des offres de location
de vélos et puis en termes de bus on a
également progressé avec des bus express
et qui se sont développés et qui nous
emmène vers les gares de versailles
chantiers ou de saint quentin en
yvelines il faut qu'on puisse encore
progressé en termes d'offre de bus
notamment le week-end et notamment le
dimanche
donc c'est des demandes que nous
continuons et que nous continuerons de
relayer vers l'agglomération
et puis il ne faut rien s'interdire en
termes de mobilité depuis longtemps je
demande maintenant une étude qui puisse
nous permettent de voir la faisabilité
d'un transport par câble entre magny les
hameaux et guyancourt et éventuellement
aussi depuis saint rémy les chevreuse
pour relier pour relier donc la future
gare de la ligne 18 c'est un élément qui
peut être intéressant mais qu'il faut
étudier tout simplement parce que on
agrandira pas les routes on sera pas de
viaduc routier
on ne fera pas de tunnel routier et il
faut qu'on passe les vannes deux autres
de vos priorités c'est lien social et la
solidarité que l'on aura bien sûr le
temps de développer au cours de cette
campagne je précise aussi qu on retrouve
vos rendez vous de campagne comme ceux
des autres candidats de magny les
hameaux sur le site internet de tv 78
merci bertrand oignons persil maire
sortant de magny les hameaux tête de
liste ensemble pour magny les hameaux
face à vous pour le scrutin
le conseil municipal d'opposition lionel
lindemann avec la liste manie citoyens
et peut-être une autre candidature la
liste reste à boucler celle de dominique
grattepain qui est ancien conseiller
municipal de
commune